And in our final section let's talk about publishing and how we actually distribute
our games once we've spent all the time building and cooking and putting all the
hard work into the projects. How do we actually get our games published? So the Unreal Engine
EULA is that you can use it for free. When you monetize and ship your game there
is a five percent royalty, but the good thing about the five percent royalty is that it's
waived on the first one million. So you wouldn't pay the five percent royalties until you started
earning over a million dollars. There's no upfront costs or subscription fees,
seat licenses, it's just you can download Unreal Engine today and start using it.
Everyone has access to the same features, you can get all the source code for Unreal Engine
and it does include all the platforms. A note about the platforms is that you would have to
reach out to the individual platform holders to get access to the source code to build for those
platforms, but once you're a registered developer on a certain platform you can then get that
platform access included and it'll work the same way as everything else does. So really user
friendly way of using Unreal Engine to deploy your games. Of course I've linked the Unreal
Engine documentation for EULA if you want to read through that yourself and it's definitely worth
looking through because you don't want any nasty surprises when shipping your games.
Now the reason why I included this slide here, you don't need to click on the article, you
could do if you want to look at it, but it's more just to reference the history of using Unreal
Engine and when Unreal Engine 4 first came out in 2014, you know the phrase we succeed when
you succeed was really apparent then in 2024 and still ongoing you know over 10 years later
and at the time Epic was giving away five million dollars to devs using Unreal Engine 4,
which since then the budget for that has blown well past that and they've been away so much,
so many you know mega grants and financial support to developers using Unreal Engine. It's
still that same ethos through to Unreal Engine 5 and onwards that you know we succeed when you
succeed and it's kind of it's just really nice to see the history of that so the article might be
worth a read but it's more from a philosophical perspective I just thought that was nice to
include. Something I really really just want to instill in everyone here which is why I've used
you know a different font color, I've used underline, I've used bold, I've used italics,
I've tried to use every tool on my PowerPoint slide formatting repository to
you know just really highlight the fact that you need to complete the form before you release
your game. So click on the URL, let Epic know that you're releasing your game, you can do it
through the developer portal as well on the Unreal Engine store but you just need to make sure you
let Epic know that you're releasing the game because that's how when we talk about the
royalties and above one million dollars and you need to report your your sales it's not a tough
or onerous process but it's just an important step on releasing a commercial project.
If you are distributing on the Epic game store which I would personally recommend everyone
does, the self-publishing tools are available to anyone, again a nice URL at the bottom here
for you to find that information and the great thing about the Epic game store is that there's
an 88-12 revenue split so 88% in favor of the developer, 12% to Epic which you know really
makes it a commercially viable option, it's a really good balance of revenue split based on
other industry metrics so you know there would be no reason in my opinion not to do that so
definitely check out the distributing your games on the Epic game store if that's something you want to do on PC.